there is something really delicious
about someone trashing your side or your
belief so I really enjoy like when I was
watching blocks as a disaffected liberal
the joke about you know you're a
conservative welcome you go to a group
of liberals we'll see yeah yeah yes
that's the the maybe the worst telling
of that joke I know I was going to say
[__] butcher please please cut to a
clip I'm
begging I'll clear it with Netflix I'll
call Ted Sandos myself the problem being
liberal is there's no amount of liberal
that's ever liberal enough like if
there's a bunch of Republicans standing
around and someone comes up and goes hey
I'm Republican they go like come on in
there's a bunch of liberals standing
around a liberal comes up and goes hey
I'm liberal they're like we'll
see you can believe the right is a
liberal but if you express it
incorrectly you're it's terrifying you
ever try to talk about like transgender
issues in public even right now you're
like we don't got to do this
Neil don't go out like your boy just
move
on